jojo was geht hier soll max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir
spielen getan und zwar alle neuen maps
die es jetzt mit einem neuen update gibt
und wir starten auf zauber fabrik ich
bin sehr gespannt wie ich mich schlagen
werde so auf den den ganzen neuen karten
für mich ich werde am ende ein kleines
resümee abgeben so kay was mir am besten
gefallen vermutlich das wo ich die
meisten points bekommen habe dann war
sehen wir einfach mal was die neuen
karten so drauf haben ist natürlich ist
meine meinung und ihr wisst schon geht
das ganze läuft so die karte hier
erinnert mich so ein bisschen sehr gut
ein bisschen erinnerte mich an bunker
muss ich sagen einfach so mit diesem
mittel ring der hier ist und so das ist
so ein element das kenne ich eigentlich
bei den bisher in getankt hatten nur von
bunker also die karte finde ich extrem
cool bisher muss ich sagen wir bis jetzt
an ein feind wenn wir runter und tut mir
leid kollege können wir finden ja wir
sind auf platz 1 auf jeden fall bin noch
relativ weit vorne sagen wir machen es
einfach leute da ist nummer eins während
die karte sogar gefinisht 770 points
kann sich sehen lassen und ich würde
gesperrt ist under und das farbschema so
von den blöcken ist erstmal ein bisschen
trist verdammt und habe auch das gefühl
es gibt extrem wo a better geht extrem
wenige blöcke habe ich das gefühl gerade
wo ich habe den eindruck dass das nicht
meine neue lieblings karte wird auch
allein wegen dem anfang jetzt gerade
haben wir schon unseren ersten colin
blog auf der map ich glaube das wird
echt nicht unsere karte kann als
resident-dj hier sind jetzt wenigstens
mal ein paar blöcke aber insgesamt habe
ich das gefühl sehr sehr reduziert die
komplette scheint nicht so 100 prozent
mein fall zu sein
ich mag einfach die karten wo man extrem
schnell sein muss viele blöcke und dann
finnischen gut glaube das geht jedem
gestern spieler so aber jetzt gerade
habe ich eine gute phase muss ich sagen
okay ach das ist ärgerlich wenn er sich
mit den ihr geholt sagte general de
gaulle den ego den ihr gut ihr kannst
wahrscheinlich alle wenn ihr selbst geht
dann spielt das ist im schlimmsten
geführt so schwierige letzte karte
regentropfen
wer kennt sie das ist die karte die wir
auch bei unserem zettel gehabt haben
franz und ich also bei unserem lucky get
down video von gestern wäre es noch
nicht gesehen hat gerne vorbeischauen
das team quantas dass die karte auch für
den regisseur gewartet und sie
freundlicherweise zur verfügung gestellt
daher kannte er sich vielleicht schon
auf der karte bin ich jetzt halt
natürlich ein bisschen geprüft warhol
bis herbst wollen wir mal sehen was wir
hier für eine bilanz ziehen
ich find die karte cool muss ich sagen
nur die keulen bilanz sage ich mal ist
ein bisschen sehr mager gerade von der
abwechslung von den farben und mit dem
mit denen gebaut ist absolut meist ich
kann kann eigentlich zu sagen dass sie
ziemlich doof ist und muss man ein
bisschen rumlaufen und sich ein paar
gedanken machen dass man auch seine
coins kommt aber das klappt gerade
zumindest auf ganz gut
wir sehen auch wieder auf platz eins und
vielleicht können wir das ganze wieder
finnischen hat mir zwei von drei bzw
zwei von sechs bisher gefehlt schon
hinter mir ist aber ein typ und ich rede
lieber ein bisschen weil ich keine lust
habe dass er mich holt bevor ich hier
finnische und da ist das ding okay leute
es geht jetzt ins erste deathmatch 1650
kann man sich nicht beschweren so läuft
ist geht es der insead noch nicht ganz
geschafft was ich auf dem bogen auf hat
leider keine unendlichkeit
das ist sehr schade uhr und da ist auch
schon der nummer eins gegner ich habe
meinen rücken und andere dass die
wahrscheinlich okay den holen wir uns
aber nichts der kollege du bist gleich
weg und zwar genau jetzt mal sehen was
wir so an equipment uns holen können
aber eigentlich sind wir gut geklappt
ich glaube nicht dass irgendjemand
größere probleme macht und da ist der
nächste gegner
so kam schon her kam ihr kollege wir
natürlich unsere fünf extra herzen da
kommt auch schon der der erste
versteckspieler 8 als ob werden jetzt
geholt hat ingolf verdammte gender
sollte ich vielleicht ein bisschen
aufpassen glaube ich warte lieber ein
bisschen bisher kollege keine reserve
hat das dürfte jetzt so mittlerweile
schon ein wenig der fall sein weil nicht
dass ihm jetzt dadurch irgendwie
erwischen lassen sehr gut leute hier
kurz bedenken ich hab das ok die briten
jetzt komplett geheilt
das war aber nicht der fall zum glück
wir suchen uns den nächsten gegner ich
weiß nicht wie neu diese deathmatch
karte hier ist ich glaube auf jeden fall
ziemlich ich weiß wenn ich hab jetzt mit
dem neuen update gekommen ist den
verwende ich hier mit einem bogen
beschossen
ich werde zusehen dass ich den bogen
bekomme bisschen tarzan spielen hier
assassin's creed ihr wisst schon bastian
ist das freezers gleiche leute kommt
raus leute mache euch nichts okay
vielleicht doch aber geheimnis aha da
vorne ist einer den namen gesehen und es
ist in der bogen typ er macht das
relativ schlaue sich hier mit uns auf
eine offene stellen zu stellen aber mit
relativ gut ausgewichen und ich glaube
er kann es nicht viel machen dann haben
wir seinen bogen läuteten haben wir ja
gut 5000 sowie sowohl 15 an bis zu den
wo willst du den gegner hin
okay leute davon ist der name kommt vom
schade nicht getroffen nicht getroffen
ok nein das wird nichts mit web trends
zu kollege jetzt ist aus und natürlich
sagen haben wir die ersten drei karten
erfolgreich abgeschlossen wir sehen uns
bei den nächsten dreier wieder bis
gleich so leute die nächsten drei stehen
an als erstes gf zelle dann kann die
band starlight wie gehabt dazu sagen was
ich so daran denke wie ich die karten
finde und hoffen dass es irgendeinen
ansatzweise interessiert so kann laut
nummer 182 points sehr schön
85 das erinnert mich irgendwie noch mehr
an bunker also irgendwie erinnert mich
alles mit einem glas finger und bunker
tut mir leid ich bin irgendwie bunker
ist aber eigentlich auch noch ganz cool
ucatis nicht ich habe immer so meinen
top 3 serap gehabt mit drei karten das
waren bunker lsd und it's me mario
irgendwie fand ich immer das waren die
coolsten gittern karten die es bisher
sogar gespannt ob sich das ändert kann
ich dazu kurz für sie noch nicht sagen
was ich da rein tun werdet verdammt
leute aber ich würde sagen die runde ist
gleich vorbei
maßlose pvp finish gleich wie kann ich
den charakter unten wir noch holen
ich fühle mich ganz sicher klassiker
okay wir haben 400 560 gesammelt geht
besser die karten scheint auch nicht so
unendlich viele computer herzugeben so
schön wir kennen die die karte habe ich
schon einmal gespielt merkt man indirekt
sehr gut passt mir sehr gut gefallen
weil sie einfach voll cool aussieht
vor nur das ist ätzend diese ganzen
karten die am anfang eine arme haben
irgendwie so weg gehen also wisst schon
was meine sind die ätzenden anfangen mit
diesen ganzen leuten die einfach runter
schlagen damit das gefühl manche leute
warten dann oben schlagen einfach andere
leute runter dabei gibt es gar keine
kunst das nicht der sinn des spiels
vertrag doch mal ob das hier ist
wahrscheinlich designtechnisch technisch
die coolste karte von den neuen mini
aber richtig geil somit den kuchen und
so kann auch essen währenddessen hat die
commerzbank schreibt die kommentare und
machten disstrack gegen brot will dass
das so der top kommend wird
ich schreibe so brot und dann räumt
jemand irgendwas roman leute ich habe zu
viel ich hab mich ein bisschen mehr aufs
spiel konzentrieren
oh gott der typ neben mir hat glaube ich
auf mich abgesehen
und ich bin dumm und töte mich selbst
wie sollte es anders sein
ich habe 20 points plus gemacht bisher
auf der karte und in 33 blöcken ist
jemand fertig da wenn's nicht läuft dann
läuft aber wirklich nicht verdammt km
schon kaum show und komm schon verdammt
leute 448 kurzen ich habe wirklich -
gemacht auf der zweiten karte
ok star wars ist extrem dunkel die karte
schon mal na ja auf das heißt das
ziemlich cool ist werden wir noch sehen
ich kann auf jeden fall gut packen
blöcke gebrauchen
davon scheint hier gefühlt nicht so viel
zu geben das wäre ich gut gewesen noch
mal so eine richtige kein blog bombe zu
haben
okay kein blog bombe leute meine gebete
wurden erhört auf star wars ist scheint
mir wieso eine karte wo eigentlich nicht
so viel ist an kein blöcken haben wir
definitiv glück gehabt sagt
grundsätzlich kann man sagen besser mehr
blöcke auf einer karte sind desto mehr
kohleblöcke gibt es auch
stehle was ich meine es wird eine
bestimmte anzahl von den vorhandenen
blöcken durch see laternen ersetzt
weshalb sind oft karten wie atlantis
oder auch schneesturm oder sowas auch
kommt schon da waren nochmal zwar
richtig schöne 752 aber das setup bringt
irgendwie insgesamt nicht so viel points
der mit dem meisten konz hat 1000 was
oben in meinem schrank ich nehme gerade
auf okay leute ich habe jetzt nicht so
optimal eingekauft weil gerade meine
schwester gerufen hat dankeschön dafür
wird jetzt mal zu sehen dass ich
irgendwie klang was vernünftiges an den
fans kommen nicht bannen nicht an
schärfe 2 hohmann schwerfahrzeuge da
dachte ich das schon nicht mehr warum
bin ich dann überhaupt auf dem boden
gegangen gegangen ich habe ich gerade
nicht mitgedacht leute nicht dass mir
das jetzt zum verhängnis wird
das wäre schade ich muss sagen von 1
karten die ich heute gespielt habe fiel
mir designtechnisch kennen die auf jeden
fall am besten ich weiß nicht genau wo
ich die meisten points bekommen habe
glaube das war bei zauberwald
wobei ich glaube nicht dass hier die
reben und dann können wir vielleicht
sogar den großen typen uns vorknöpfen
sag ich mal extra disney gesprintet
der typ auf jeden fall okay ja der macht
uns zu viel damit sprintet uns liegt der
typ daneben saß zumindest aus es wird
eine dass die ganze zeit machen ist
einfach mal ganz penetrant und boxen den
typen
das konnte nichts werden
ärgerlich ärgerlich ich habe jetzt
einfach alle 96 gestern karten gezeigt
habe ich gesagt weil ich davon halte
wenn er ist cool fanden schreibt es in
die likes his